joining me today is an actor a stand-up
comic the host of American Ninja Warrior
and a guy whose birthday today Matt
Iseman happy birthday Dave thank you so
much I'm a little under the weather I'm
a little hoarse here but this is a great
birthday gift I always say one of the
great choices since I moved out to LA
was that we should want to make sure I
for my do something on my birthday
because that's what I love doing so this
is it you're my gift to myself how old
are you I'm 40
48:40 48 which sounds so old and yet I
don't know no that's 42 48 no longer
than 48 sounds old because I still in my
head see myself in my 20s yeah and it's
hard it's really hard to shift that that
that that thought process because I'm
still still I'm dating girl but no kids
so no commitment none of those
responsibilities I know you're married I
think those are the kind of things that
make you those are the markers in life
that might make you feel okay
I've matured yeah but I've regretted in
everything I've done I've I talked about
ninjas for a living I got stand-up
comedy so there's nothing that would
make me feel like an adult other than
seeing that 48 yeah next to my name and
somehow through it all 48 years and
maybe it's that you don't have kids big
smile on your face so you know I think I
was a naturally enthusiastic kid my mom
we have a they called me they my the
sunshine boy and I I think you know the
the word I always used if there was one
adjective I would say to describe myself
it was enthusiastic I get excited about
things and that's one of the one of the
things I think that was it was a gift
for me and and to have found a career
where you get rewarded for that and
especially you should like ninja warrior
which deals and hype and hyperbole where
the more enthusiastic I am the better it
is that's become a thing unto itself it
really is and it's it's it's been it's I
think also having switched careers
midstream in life gave me such an
appreciation for being able to do
something that I love
because you look at so many people and I
always think of the song working for the
week everybody's working for the weekend
that idea of a job is supposed to be
toil
it's supposed to be argue Asst it's
supposed to be something you do to
provide for your family and then allow
you to have that free time we've found a
way to disrupt the system and do
something we love it's bizarre it's the
best and it's one of those things of if
you can do it and and and and I edit
this my dad deserves the credit cuz that
you know I was a I was a doctor my dad's
a doctor and he was a professor of
medicine at the University of Colorado
where I was doing residency and my dad
is a world-renowned physician he's the
man I respect more than any other person
on this planet he is he is the smartest
the best the kindest the wisest man I've
ever known
every time I have the wrong ice minutes
and you totally do my dad is my dad is
he's a legend like you he's Iron Mike he
is just and and so to be he's following
in his footsteps and to know to feel
like you know obviously I think he was
he was very proud of it so when I sensed
that medicine wasn't my passion and that
I needed to take a step back and
reevaluate because I couldn't in good
conscience be a doctor knowing my heart
wasn't a hundred percent in it I felt
like I was a fraud I felt like I was not
doing a service to my patients and
certainly not to myself the the scariest
moment was telling my dad and I remember
when I told him the first words he said
where life is short do what makes you
happy so I've got that very quote from
your dad right here because it's the
first thing that you say on your about
page on your size all the interesting
thing because in a certain way it's sort
of sounds cliche do what makes you happy
it is clear yet it's almost the best
advice or only advice that you can give
that one I don't a certain level yeah
you know certainly it's not a
Shakespearean line but I thought it was
just you know particularly for him to
say it at a moment when very easily
probably most parents would be you're
crazy there's there's a lot of money
invested in this education this is a
stable job you don't walk away from it
for him to instead say all we care about
is you being happy and you know I've
talked them so many times about it
marveled that he could have mustered
those words because my dad's an amazing
man he's also he worked hard for
everything he had and and I was very
fortunate to have more opportunities
because of his hard work and the work of
my mom and and I think too you know when
he says I'm like how could I ever repay
that he say just if you ever have kids
someday do the same for them it's that
pay it forward mentality and it's that
thing of I don't know it's a it makes me
appreciate though the opportunity that I
have I know how lucky I am to be out
here getting to do this and how lucky I
am to have tried medicine and and
learned so much from it and learned so
much and be given so much perspective
about what truly is life or death and to
be out here in entertainment where we
feel like everything is life or death
but realize it's just silliness its
silliness and it's so much fun what we
get to do yet we still do have a chance
to make a difference yeah well you can
do something real and still enjoy yeah
that's the thing wait so let's back up a
bit so your dad's a doctor yeah was it
just sort of a foregone conclusion that
you were gonna no no it wasn't he never
pressured me into it it was more I think
lead by example it was you know the
funny thing was I think I kind of had a
crisis during college because I worked
there was just in growing up it was you
work hard you play sports you go to
school you excel you achieve and that's
the path you're on but I never kind of
stopped to say Archy stuff right then
work hard succeed right yeah but I never
stopped to think what's what's the end
where am I headed and so then you know
when I kind of poked my head a midway
through college you go what where am I
headed and I looked around and I thought
you know that's when I thought okay I
like science
I like people and I looked at my dad as
someone who I respected tremendously and
saw the satisfaction he got from
medicine now I think he was a little
prescient in seeing that medicine was
changing and and doctors were losing
autonomy in that medicine today is
radically different than it was thirty
years ago so I think he saw that that
there was probably going to be some
disruptions in the field of medicine but
it seemed on paper the perfect
job but it's so interesting you know
that's what you realize is you know it's
it's like when you watch sports or
something you know you don't play a game
on paper you don't live your life on
paper what what looks like it might be
perfect that sometimes it's just that
divine spark is missing that that
whatever it is that intangible thing and
I'm so lucky to have somehow stumbled
into performing and finding that I love
an audience I love being in front of the
camera I love doing stand-up comedy I
love being on Ninja Warrior these are
things where no matter how sick I am no
matter how tired am if it's like when
you get on stage and you have an
audience I just feel like I feel present
I feel alive it's such a rush did you
have a moment when you realized it was
wrong for you yes there was a moment it
was in January of 1999 I was in the ICU
it was probably 3:00 in the morning you
know I'd been up for 18 hours we were
getting slammed I think we had seven
admits so this super-sick people are
rolling in and I'm a resident I'm and
I'm an intern first in first year out of
med school and I had a second year with
me and there's there's also an attending
but he wasn't in the hospital so at this
point the guy was like the person who
was overseeing me was just like just you
got it right some orders you got to make
some choices make some decisions for
these people and I'm all of a sudden
realizing these people's lives now are
in my hands and and I just thought I'm
sitting there going I want to be skiing
or playing Nintendo or or I don't want
to be here I didn't feel like this is
the moment I've trained for it wasn't
like er I jumped on top of a gurney and
started doing CPR yeah it was just this
moment of I felt like a fraud I felt
like my heart you know all this training
all this and and I loved medical school
I loved the problem-solving elements of
it but I realized I think there was
there's just something I I think there
are jobs and there are callings medicine
is a calling it is not something that
you just do 9:00 to 5:00 it is something
that consumes you that you are obsessed
with your your patients are obsessed
with being up-to-date on the information
and giving them the best care possible
and and if you're if you don't hear that
calling if it's just a job for you
that's awful
because it is it is such a consuming
profession and you know and when you
look at the opportunity cost of someone
who goes to medical school and it's
going six figures into that versus my
friends who went into finance and or
making six figures and then during
residency you're making subsistence
level wages as your debt continues to
grow some of these people will never get
out from under that that debt and and
you end up working this career and
making choices that you might not want
to or practicing the way you would want
to or giving the level of care that you
would want to when you think I do
believe that health care in America is
going to see a radical shift in the in
the next few decades because people
aren't going to be able to afford to go
into medicine anymore or want to yeah
it's such a fascinating thing because
it's like wow you trained your whole
life for something okay now you make you
have this moment right yeah wake up
woman what happens the next day so you
know my mom my mom said something like
there's no wasted education and she's so
right like so when I came out to LA I
literally I packed up I packed up a
u-haul I moved out to LA September 199
and I got the LA Weekly I got the back
page you know John's playing home and
and so I just started finding open mics
and I just started going to open mics
and I'm just honestly when I came out
here it wasn't as though I said I'm
going to be a standard comedian part of
me thought I'm gonna take a year and I'm
gonna grow up I'm gonna get this out of
my system and realize I'm fortunate to
be a doctor and I'll go back an adult
yeah that's is kind of what I thought 20
years ago so you're yeah eight late 20s
late 20s and I can't really understand
the open mic situation god I remember
awful I remember when I was doing it and
it's like it's like a terrible you know
couple years that you have to do as a
comic as you're figuring out your [ __ ]
but I remember there would be doctors
there lawyers there there would be
professionals and I every time I saw one
of them
I'd be like what in the world
is wrong with you right here you're a
real person you're a functioning person
and yet they were there because they had
something in them that there's something
there's something you know I think I
think everybody has that we all search
for purpose we all search for something
that that that ignites a fire in us and
rare is the person that finds I think
the job that does that and I think we're
so lucky to have found something and
again what do you think it's luck what
you're okay we took the chance and we
certainly went out there I still think
there is a certain amount of fortune or
or circumstance or something you know
I'm not gonna say I'm Christopher
Columbus who boldly decided to explore
the frontiers of the job world walked
away from medicine I was lucky in that
my family supported me I was lucky in
that when I came out you know you meet
the right people look luck is what
preparation we said whatever cliches we
want to spout out yeah I thought you'd
have a good one I I don't I don't know I
mean I'd never been called on that day
you're very good I I do think it's
partly luck or kismet or magic of just
putting the work in all those things
having said that you're right
I I think that once I realized it was
this that's where the medicine came in
so handy in that medicine taught me such
a discipline and and such an ability to
work on process information and to just
withstand a river of [ __ ] being dumped
on you where you're like this is this is
easy right I'm not on third call for 36
hours you're asking me to see there with
craft services and have someone do
makeup and be pampered that fine yeah
fine great I love this it can be a lot
of waiting around which is quite it is
and you know the it's a business well
here's here's where it really helped is
Hollywood is a business of no you you go
out for a hundred things and 99 times
you're told no and often you're told
nothing you're not given a reason why
you might have been amazing
you're never told why and if you don't
have something that provides you with
that sense of self that sense of it's
okay I know I am talented if you don't
have that belief
then I think people really crumble and
the people who succeed aren't
necessarily the most talented they're
the ones who persist they're the ones
who can slog it out and you know this
we've seen it the 15 20 year overnight
success where somebody pops and like oh
my god this guy came out of nowhere and
you like no I'm doing it for 20 years
yeah and they finally they got
recognized and that's why they're so
good is because they've been doing it
for 20 years
I heard Susie Essman you know the
comedian yeah Curb Your Enthusiasm I've
heard her say that everyone says she's
an overnight success and she always goes
you know and she's got a great potty
mouth she's always like well where the
[ __ ] were you for 20 years yeah
which it's like yeah there's a lot of
work but you know and and honestly
though it it it's a it does two things
am makes you appreciate it but B it also
makes you ready for it because if I'd
come out here and gotten a show one
weekend you you wouldn't have had the
chops you wouldn't have known how to do
it you wouldn't have had the ability to
know right from wrong or to make the
right decisions I think that's what you
learn over those 20 years of hard knocks
you know you you start to see you get
these opportunities performing in front
of four people so when you go out there
and you're like there is nothing a guy I
hosted a live show on the History
Channel with travis Pastrana where we
created the Evel Knievel stunts for
three hours half the time people are
just like just talk like okay yeah I can
do that I've done that that's what I've
been trained for and so it was so great
to feel like you you you're ready for
things and I I did I was just talking
about Celebrity Apprentice I was with
Arnold Schwarzenegger this weekend and
the show got politicized nobody watched
it but what was great about it was it
was so much fun for me because it called
on I felt everything I had done in my
life to that point whether it been
playing sports or being a doctor or
going to school or stand-up or hosting
or anything you you called on all these
different skills that it's so much fun
when you feel ready when an opportunity
comes and you're like I am ready for
this opportunity there's nothing you
could throw me that I can't handle and
and I would much rather have someone go
where have you been then see you too
early ago
miles all right but next all right so
we've got the beginnings of a nice
Hollywood story here but for a content
it took a turn for the worse
crumbles no but but you know they say
the comedy comes from pain I'm not
seeing what I mean well you know I think
I always say people they those people I
think I think there's um I think people
go into comedy for one of two reasons
they weren't hugged enough as a child
pain or they were hugged too much I was
definitely the latter where I had a
mother who just showered me with
attention and affection and praise and
she was always mad you know you oh
that's so funny
whatever I did was amazing and she made
me believe have this ridiculous
confidence this and she was always there
she was always there I had this
unbelievable sense of a safety net from
my mom and my dad and I think that
that's what gave me the confidence to
think I could come out here and take a
swing and be okay and know that I could
fall flat on my face and either go back
to medicine and my parents wouldn't
disown me and and but but ultimately I
believed yeah I you what I've realized
in life is nothing is certain and and I
look at I have a ton of friends who were
in finance had a friend who's at Bear
Stearns when it imploded and you know
saw people lose 60 million dollars
overnight and these guys who thought
they were gonna be able to retire all of
a sudden our out of a job and broke and
you know you go into you choose some of
these careers thinking alright I'm gonna
work my ass off but it'll pay off in the
end and you realize they're nothing's
guaranteed and so I think to what I
realize is the best bet in life you can
make is to bet on yourself because
that's where you have the most control
and so while this career I were in well
is so fickle so on the surface fickle
we're you know my show they live in a
week-to-week with ratings oh my god it's
it's up a pointer it's down a point and
and you think it could end at any moment
and we and we make our peace with that
but ultimately what I've realized is
having been out here 19 years I've
worked and I just have to have this calm
the only way I can sleep at night is to
say if it goes away something else will
come I'll bet on myself and I think
that's one of those things in life that
is hard to get to but if you can is a
great position to be in is when you say
I'd rather bet on myself than someone
else then you're lying on someone else
to provide me as you have you run out on
your own yeah I mean I feel that very
intimately because even just in the last
couple months with this patreon thing
the rubber met the road and I like can I
make a move here that's a huge risk and
not and I did make the move and and it's
worked and I found that if you're if
you're just present enough and aware
enough of what really is going on and
you put in the work that you generally
make the right moves right you're gonna
do some missteps along the way yeah but
but that generally speaking the right
path will kind of you gotta shoot though
you got to take that shot you got to
think that's okay and it's a-you know
with Ninja Warrior one of the things we
see is everybody falls everybody's gonna
have a misstep everyone's gonna have a
show get canceled it's not the end you
just get back up and you learn from it
you keep going some people are
devastated by that some people can't
handle that that failure and you just
have to realize that it's not a failure
it's it's just this was one thing that
didn't work but hopefully it'll lead you
to the next thing that does are you
shocking the amount of people that are
just afraid to do something special no
you're like I get it I mean again you
know III think I was I was very lucky to
have parents who were incredibly
supportive so and I was also like I
think to have been exposed to enough so
even though I you know my life had
always been very much set towards you
know sports school achievement it was
set towards you know lawyer finance
doctors something that there was enough
exposure to think that it was possible
to have it outside of that so for a
random person who's growing up without
parents who are encouraging him I I
think it's hard I know how lucky I was
to have parents who gave me that sense
of confidence in that sense of anything
is possible so for the average person I
would the people who amaze me are the
people you know I watch that movie I
Tania about Tonya Harding
one of the things that struck me there
were two things that struck me one was
how remarkable it was that this girl
from the trailer parks went into this
sport and through sheer will and
athleticism made it to the top but out
the thing I didn't like about the movie
was that while it purported to tell her
story I thought there was a little
winking and judgmental of she's still
white trash trailer park and when you
told when you really saw the story of
how her mom would hire people to yell at
her I don't know that you know you
wanted to be a sympathetic figure but at
least you understood what this woman
overcome and the for the tenacious the
ferocious - tenacity she had to
persevere in this world where she was
such an outsider those are the people
who amazed me yeah I mean I I'm I know I
was very fortunate to to have a lot of
opportunities that gave me the
confidence to take my shot so look and
the other thing was like when I moved
out here I didn't have a family I didn't
have kids I didn't have responsibilities
so for that person who's sitting there
those are the people you know if you
have a wife and kids and you can say I'm
gonna risk our future to take this shot
that's those are the people I think I
really salute right it's a little harder
to though yeah the doctor or the lawyer
or the finance guy or the janitor who is
like I got some kids and now I'm
quitting and I'm going to do stand-up
comedy we got a different situation yeah
and it's it's it is hard and it's it's
uh you know one of the things I love
with American Ninja Warrior to
shamelessly promote but but is to see
these people who have families who have
jobs and still find time to train for
this ridiculous thing because it's their
passion and when you see that it's
that's what I love about it is because I
think it's it's kind of it sums up the
American Dream of its it's just
bootstraps it's that there's no there's
no secret formula
I work hard have you seen people that
have been too absolutely wrapped in that
thing whatever that thing may be well
you'd be a comedy be it you know sure of
course of course you know I think I
think there's a you know there's there's
obsession and
and a healthy obsession then there's you
know a consuming obsession yeah I think
with American Ninja we're for the most
part there's a there's the community is
there's such a positive supportive
community that we haven't seen people
you know go off the rails
the good news is look I don't think any
of them are you know using peds they're
too expensive these guys are making a
lot of money
I think they're really are leading out
the lifestyle but more importantly it's
a supportive lifestyle but certainly
with comedy you've seen lots of you know
lots of friends who comedy is a very
lonely existence when you're on the road
now I'm lucky that with TV I get to do
comedy selectively and not have to be
out there 40 50 weeks a year in strange
cities where you're working two hours a
day and 22 hours you're in a strange
city with nothing to do and no one
around and that is a that is a existence
that's kind of fun when you're 20 but
when you get near 40s is incredibly
lonely 1850s it's very hard yeah I
remember when I was maybe six or seven
years into stand-up I was doing some of
my first road gigs I was opening at
bananas in Poughkeepsie New York for
Bobcats
stop bragging about it was great Bobcats
great he was really great actually
and the shows were sold out so they had
to move us out of the club he was in the
Best Western Wow
Best Western in begin Wow move us out of
the comedy club into a ballroom so it's
you know I don't know five six hundred
people I think we did six shows over in
three nights or something like that but
I remember on the last night that the
show ends and I'm alone in Poughkeepsie
and it's freezing it out and I'm
starving and the restaurants closing
there's nothing else sadly there and I
remember I walk up to the vending
machine at the end of the hallway and I
got skittles and I laid in bed eating
skittles you know in a bikini after when
I was in my life and I was like I'm
actually depressed yeah that's how warm
this thing is you have some of those
moments I remember that I was sitting
there and yeah same thing like in Ohio
walking around going what am i doing
walking to a McDonald's at 2:00 in the
minute but but it's I don't know I
thought if you did you see the
documentary comedian which are a
Seinfeld that you know the story of the
band
yeah like walking through the snow they
see this family celebrating Christmas
what who would live like that and I
think there is there is just a certain
you know you you have a certain mindset
of I have to be on stage but it does get
hard and it does get lonely and so it's
nice to find something that allows you a
little more stable lifestyle with Ninja
Warrior we're really only shooting about
23 days a year and so the majority of
the time I can be around LA Acme around
my girlfriend and we can lead largely of
normal existence and pick and choose
when I go out for stand-up and so right
now I'm in an in a very fortunate
situation but it could change at any
moment so I'm also at the same time
there's always a fire under my ass that
thing of you always have to be hustling
to make sure to find that next thing
because as we've seen things can get
taken away from you very quickly you
could say something at any moment that
could end so this is what this is really
why one of the things that's most
fascinating to me when you make a living
with words right now one of the things
that amazes me is that the artistic
community and comedians in particular
haven't been more vocal and supporting
people because again well I am a clean
comic and the shows I do are completely
family-friendly and and I try to be in
the middle of the road I also know that
those people who were out there on the
edges guys like Doug Stanhope or Jim
Norton those who are pushing those
envelopes they're keeping that area of
speech protected mmm
because once you've cede an area once
it's taken away once we say okay you
know we can't joke about that you'd
never get that back and to me it's not
that I've where I feel the power of
comedy is is the power to talk about
very difficult very touchy subjects in a
way in a disarming way through humor now
I've had rheumatoid arthritis and I've
had cancer and when I tell those stories
I tell them as funny as possible those
are stories that you know aren't
necessarily the best stories to tell but
it's amazing what you can talk about
when you use humor and when we take some
of those topics off the table for comedy
I think we really lose an important tool
for us to
communicating for us to find common
ground and that's why it's so amazing to
me as we see this now where this there's
this almost this agreement of yeah we're
growing certain topics now are no longer
you can't joke about it or and we're
gonna go back and apply it retroactively
yeah well did you see just in the last
couple weeks that the producers of
FAMILY GUY said that they're not going
to do gay jokes anymore it's like you
guys have done gay everyone has I mean
they're they're one of their iconic bits
with that musical the musical wait well
there's a zillion musicals but which one
was it everyone has AIDS
Oh aids aids yeah I think they just kept
repeating it yeah certainly falling and
and again it's it's like or every
character is a ridiculous stereotype
right it's like so we're not which
groups how do we decide which groups
we're not gonna make jokes about these
really actually equality is that you
everyone will make fun of everyone
really I think South Park does that
better than it either everything is fair
game or nothing is fair game
no he said that if you want to evolve if
you say you know what I I no longer want
to tell those jokes that's fine
more power to you make the choice of
your own volition
you know whatever you find funny is
great maybe you've had some personal
waking whatever it is but I just think
again what I don't like is the idea of
people saying you can't joke about it
mm-hmm like if you choose not to great
yeah again I choose not to joke about a
lot of things I'm just not comfortable
you know I always picture my grandma in
the crowd or my mom I want people to be
entertained I don't want to alienate
people that's me but I love listening to
some of the filthiest comics talk about
things and or joke about cancer or
things that have impacted me and and and
I find it hilarious and I find a
cathartic to laugh about it and I think
because someone else doesn't you know
may have had a bad experience with it
doesn't mean that someone shouldn't be
able to joke about it I just think that
this is a really interesting time
because social media gives voice to
people and we see where one or two
people protesting can change a network
and that's what's what's remarkable is
we really don't see these networks
saying you know 99% of people may not
care would they cave to this smaller
percentage yeah and again often it'd be
nice for them to say okay boycott we
stand behind
performers we stand behind this content
yeah so it's a weird time to be a comic
I mean so I I did stand-up for 12 years
in New York then I came here I started
doing this I was doing something else
that I liked I stopped doing it this
could be even more dangerous so now I
started again in June and now I'm
selling out clubs all over the country
and I don't care that much so I'm having
the most fun I've ever had right I do an
hour and I'm messing around with the
crowd now but you have people coming out
to see you is the best so that way
that's a game-changer because when
people come out and they you know
they're there for you they know
something about you you can do insider
stuff as opposed to just being the
eighth white guy out of 12 comics and
they're like who the hell that guy was
hilarious well name you know and then
and then that's it but but it's an odd
time to be doing stand-up knowing that
people could be in the crowd recording
you they're waiting to take you down and
they are and you know and that's the
workshop that that's you know that's not
where you're that's what you're learning
the medicine is where you're performing
the surgery it is and and no other you
know Jim Norton III give so much credit
for for talking about how comics are
held to a different standard than any
other artists so say you're an actor
and you go on SVU and you play the most
reprehensible character nobody believes
that you are that person right but as a
comedian what they don't understand is
sometimes you will say something
hyperbolic you will say something
ironically to make a point it's that
what you actually believe but because
it's Dave Rubin saying it they take you
literally going wait you missed the
entire point of the joke you missed the
joke I uh my point was the exact
opposite but nobody will give you the
credit for the context and people often
just see the written words and it's it's
really unfortunate and then and and
again what people don't understand and
and Jim was just talking about this with
Judd Apatow in the case of louis c.k is
jokes don't spring fully-formed jokes
can take weeks months years to be honed
it's so hard especially if it's a topic
that is delicate to find the phrasing
and to say I'm gonna tackle a subject
that nobody thinks that can make funny
and I'm gonna find a way to make it
funny it's gonna take me a while and I'm
gonna stumble through and I'm gonna get
some groans and I get some people
alienated not me I talk about various
you know ridiculous things but yeah I
appreciate those comics who can go there
and say
a subject that I would say I will never
laugh at this you made me laugh at this
despite that they're not I think Doug
stand-up is one of the best examples of
someone who will take the most taboo
subjects and make you laugh despite you
you might be violently opposed to the
way he thinks but he's funny yeah and
and when you do that there's it's it's
such a way of opening up your mind to
saying okay let me let me let me rethink
these things and maybe it doesn't but it
but it but it just proves that I think
anything can be funny
anything can be fair game and I think
it's important that we allow comedians
to have this full range of words and
emotions to use because that's we're
talking about the human condition and I
think comedians really do have a great
job and that we can bring up some of
these topics in a way that you know when
you see it happen on Tucker Carlson
people might go to fisticuffs but in the
comedy club you laugh about it you know
what maybe maybe my crazy uncle's not so
crazy maybe we can talk yeah well that's
why it's so strange that I'm doing this
again because I feel like they dragged
me into it because I've seen a lot of
comics who I love that have become the
word police they've become the
hysterical right crew on Twitter who are
calling for books not to be printed and
all of this stuff amazing I always think
it's like man if Carlin was alive what
would he be doing right right he'd be
making fun of [ __ ] but recently say yeah
or or would he be demanding that people
be booted off platforms or silenced or
otherwise and it's like what a strange
place for an artist and you see
eventually it consumes them the
eventually it comes back to bite them
because nobody is perfect nobody nobody
is without a flaw nobody's without you
know having nobody has led their lives
like Jesus we've all done something or
said something or tried to make a joke
that at some point if you went back
people would say that's wrong and you'd
be like okay but that was ten years ago
or any it is an odd time I think that
that people aren't particularly
comedians yeah aren't more supportive
instead are really leading this
book-burning charge well that's why this
this Family Guy thing act me so much
it's like you guys did this for 20 years
I'm not even I don't know obsessed even
that
seth macfarlane I don't even know if
he's that much involved in the show
anymore but like it's like you did this
for 20 years and now it's like you're on
the other side a success kind of so like
are you are we a more tolerant society
because we're not going to joke about
certain people now does that make us
more time like that just seems odd to me
you know you know it's really it's it's
a funny thing where and I'd love to have
him here and that's not even it's really
not a judgment on him is right why this
and then what about yeah
what other topic right so it's like okay
so you can't make fun of gays like
should we get where's the list where's
the loans that list who owns it who
judges it who's you know and and and and
that list is shifting and what's crazy
is you see it's not the joke it's who
says it yeah because you know the same
person to people can say the same joke
one person gets celebrated one person
gets vilified so it's not the words it's
who's saying them and that's wrong it
should be absolutely it should be either
this is a fair game or not it shouldn't
be based on what we're getting to is you
know papers please
yeah papers to prove that you are of
this group so you can talk about this
topic and it's like either the topic is
fair game or it's not either everyone
can talk about it that's what I believe
but again you know I I realize I'm I'm
the white male so I you know I also am
you know I don't know oh no wait what
I've been with you this whole time why
should you shut up in this know that
you're doing a little target cheekers
what I was is I always feel the need
this is one of the what I hate oh now
you're going to yes you feel the need to
shoot caveats where you feel the need to
say you know I
I don't like homophobia but I think
Family Guy can make jokes well you know
where it's like of course no where you
you normally would have see that's the
concession you're making just cuz you're
a good person I I think I used to do a
lot of that too and now I'm just sort of
over it's like well that's because you
own your platform at UC might be
watching this same so right but nothing
you've said is homophobic obviously
we're talking about the nature jokes or
or that they don't want our blue in the
Simpsons anymore well you see you know
crazy of what I don't like also was the
guilt by association yeah where you know
I thought micros said that someone was
criticizing micro for going on on Rush
Limbaugh and then Rachel Maddow you know
and people were complaining on both
sides he's like going on a show doesn't
mean I implicitly endorse every single
stance that person has no it means I'm
talking to somebody I'm expressing my
opinions they may have different
opinions that's a discussion and I just
wish we would allow more of that because
otherwise all you're saying is people I
approve of talking to people I approve
of so all you're hearing is what you
want to hear I think that's what we miss
is reasoned people having reasoned
discussions unfortunately when you turn
on the TV
we know hyperbole yeah hyperbole moves
the needle is not you know politically
and you see that and I think that's it's
you know III told you before I give you
full credit what I love is and Joe Rogan
does the same thing I think you guys are
willing to have people on you might
disagree with and you're not looking for
a gotcha moment you're not looking for
confrontations you're looking for
understanding like help me understand
your position let me help you understand
my position
maybe there's agreement maybe there
isn't but for the listeners at least
they're being informed there's they're
hearing different points of view does it
strike you as odd that that seems so
unique these days like I've had people
in here I think people don't seek it out
yeah I think you know and I think you
know we look at the universities we look
at places where I think people are
taught you know diversity of thought or
a different thought that there that
there is one right daughter that you
shouldn't have these discussions and I
think that's a you know we've always I
mean I look at I look at medicine and
and it's it's so amazing how medicine we
you know you think you deal in absolutes
you think you deal in complete science
black and white but we see a new study
talked about sunscreen how actually
sunscreen may not be healthy because we
the reality is melanoma which is
completely deadly is only about 1% of
skin cancers and it is awful but people
are putting so much sunscreen on they're
not getting any of the beneficial
vitamin D we're seeing an increase in
cardiac disease heart
disease is killing so many more people
than melanoma so now dermatologists are
thinking maybe we shouldn't be wearing
as much sunscreen so you see these
truths that we thought were absolute
being challenged because people look at
the Dana V look at empirical things when
it comes to life and death were able to
do that when it comes to political
topics which are just as important I
think it's much harder to do it because
they're so politically charged that
people don't want to look at the data
they want to look at how they feel about
them or these emotions or what it stirs
up and if someone presents a
counter-argument you're dismissed or
debunked or D platformed yeah what do
you consider yourself politically I I
think I'm a little more you know I I am
vehemently free speech I am vehemently
people should live their lives the way
they want to live them i I think I'm
moderate to right would would would
probably be it I don't like the
government taxing us too and I don't
think the government is great at a lot
of things like health care but at the
same time you know really function in
Hollywood with a set of ideas well
here's the other thing is I tend not to
talk politics because it isn't my
purview my like I'm an entertainer and
I'm the last person if people are
getting their political opinions from
the host of American Ninja Warrior think
again I think for me I what what I like
is you know for me I I never talk
politics on stage I never I would rather
bring people together I'm not looking to
alienate people or try to be clever it's
I I think that's I leave that to Louis
black or guys who are very good at that
that's that's our area to tackle the
political humor that's just not my thing
i I think I again I just think in in
Hollywood the one thing I think that is
so important is is the exchange of ideas
and that's what I think is being
compromised right now and that's the
thing that that I try to theater that I
really want people to to fight for
because again once we cede that ground
we're not getting it back all right so
let's shift to this minja war Ninja
Warrior for something love would you say
that it so it's something that as a joke
it actually you can hear I'm hoarse I am
a very loud adds a little something well
I so this this was I was in hosting the
Arnold Pro strongman World Series and at
Santa Monica so it was five hours
non-stop of and went into the show so
for those who don't know America and
American Ninja Warrior started say it
was a Japanese show Sasuke it was poured
into America and dubbed it started doing
so well on g4 they made an American
version yeah in the second season they
realize they had something and they're
like okay
we're gonna put some money into this and
we're bringing in two new hosts and they
found me and I think that we're looking
for a Joe Rogan there's some bigger guys
but I don't care you know it's like the
lights come up at 2 a.m. in the morning
and like the pretty girl goes alright
I'll go home with you I might have been
their last choice I'm just happy to be
here Brogan's got enough stuff so I
started doing the show and you know we
would be going for eight or nine hours a
day calling these runs and it's all ten
out of ten because it was based on the
Japanese show and so my my sports
calling technique comes just from years
of watching sports watching the Japanese
show and being an enthusiastic guy I'm
always yeah hyperbolic yeah but it was
really straining on the voices we were
shooting these ins and outs where it's
coming up next on American Ninja Warrior
and I was a little gravelly and the and
so I was kind of making a point like hey
my voice is kind of shot so I was like
American Ninja Warrior and the producers
like ooh do that do more that especially
in the fourth year if you watch the
earlier seasons I'm like next on
American me do it so rally it was none
of that so we just kind of born out of
blowing out my voice and now it's become
like this signature thing that I love if
they do anything for your voice a lot of
my friends who are you know so I've gone
do a lot of voice coaches and tried to
obviously they really were so effective
it's but I mean even on the medical side
of things make sure you're not blowing
out your book you know I I see an ENT on
a regular basis I'll do so we'll go to
Vegas and we'll do six out of seven days
where we're shooting at night but it's
still 100 degrees in dust for you know
eight hours in a row 10 out of 10 energy
and those all do IVs and
anti-inflammatories and steroids just to
try to maintain the vocal cords and
vocal rest
but I you know you you I'm going back
trying to learn better technique it's
it's almost like rock singers I look at
Brian Johnson from ac/dc who was like
you know that guy was doing it at 70 the
most vocally taxing way so that's one of
the things is is trying to learn how to
preserve the voice to work for that long
speaking of rock stars I saw this
morning that you tweeted something about
Steve Perry from journey now I love
journey love love loved you're my
favorite band in the world I love Steve
Perry I love the fact that he's back now
yes because he had had some boy stuff
actually speaking of guy yeah I mean he
basically lost his voice well I can't
say this completely on camera suffice to
say he kind of lives near here and I may
or may not know the Mexican joint that
he goes to so so today this is birthday
it's Steve Perry's birthday so Steve
Perry shara birthday and I'm not I'm not
lying so for my 30th birthday never met
him yeah for I I've been a journey fan
since I can remember and and I for my
38th birthday at the Brown Derby the
last night of the Brown Derby we closed
it down
I hired a journey cover band and I had
them play and I still have this fantasy
that someday on my birthday I'm gonna be
singing faithfully or don't stop
believing and all of a sudden another
guy's gonna walk out behind me and it's
gonna be Barry and we're gonna do a duet
together and arm an arm just singing
like faithfully at the end yeah
just that that's my fans well Steve if
you're watching I hope he's a huge fan
of Ninja Warrior because he I just
listened that voice yeah I I think he
had one of the most unique yeah and
Arnel Pineda is remarkable about the
story nah it's an incredible story yeah
but you listen to Steve and you listen
to the passion and the range and there's
the unique notes that guy would hit it
was incredible i i'm just i love journey
i love their songs i love the 80s
I love the unabashed passion and and and
and glory there's no cynicism and and
it's just awesome every every time I do
stand-up an hour when I do like a public
speaking thing and bright blue you know
right before you start they go what song
do you want to go up to
and the only thing that ohi's pops into
my mind is separately is my journey that
that beginning oh my god video when
they're playing the keyboard too much
power
yeah those teens then I I mean it's just
you know yeah you coupe don't stop
believin are anyway you want it and I
have so many great songs that when you
just hear it they're just toe tappers
and I mean granted you know if you grew
up in the eighties it was the soundtrack
of our youth so so much of it takes us
back to there but Steve Perry is just
he's one of he's been one of the one of
the great artists I think what journey
is done and I would love I saw them up
in San Francisco and Neal Schon was
shouting around I thought I wonder if
Steve's gonna come out on stage for that
along of made it yeah well they just got
inducted to the Rock Hall and yeah it's
you know I a lot of bad blood I think
get over but but yeah anyway that's a
sidebar for us side let's get back to
that ninja thing so if what like what
some looks some sort of insider
something that you can give us about
what these guys are like you know it's
it's what you see is what you thing is
they really are the people you see they
are these people who are incredibly
hard-working and so generous and
supportive of one another we had a woman
Maggie thorne and she was she was open
about that she was going through a
really tough divorce and she had three
little girls and during that time she
started traveling around the country
visiting her ninja sisters as she called
them people like Berkeley stock and
Jessi flex Labrecque Michelle market she
just talked about how had she not had
this community she wasn't sure what she
would have done to get through it and
you see it's been unlike any other sport
I mean a we've only had one winner in
ten seasons like what other show like I
think about like at the end of America's
Got Talent
you know they come and go well turns out
America doesn't have town there's no
winner and yet you know it's a show
where every single person who's competed
on the show has fallen at one point so
it's a show that would seem to be filled
with failure and yet when you watch it
you feel like you're seeing more success
than ever and I think we
we've stumbled into a formula where you
see it's these are really every day
they're truly everyday people they're us
there are people who have jobs have
families who've you know dealt with
substance abuse or cancer or the loss of
a loved one whatever it is loss of a job
and yet are trying to work through it
and you see the obstacle course is just
a metaphor for the obstacles they've
overcome in life and you know we tell
the the thing we do I think better than
most shows is in 90 seconds we give you
a reason to care about these people and
then we show you we let you cheer for
them and it's it's the Olympic formula
of I don't give I don't care about
curling but you tell me this guy work
sit-ups he's got a new baby on the way
and it's like a Bruce Springsteen song
and when he's up there brushing I'm like
you go buddy you know Flynn's jurgen
from Norway where you you just find
yourself cheering for him and I think
it's this it's this thing of one of the
things I love I love doing that like the
strongman competition or ninja I work
you know with travis Pastrana this evil
thing I love watching people push the
envelope or do things they didn't think
they could do I love people seeing
people have their moment because I think
one of the things in life that helps
define you that helps give you the
confidence is to have a Super Bowl
moment to have to have a moment where
you you win you're victorious in
something whether it's you get a job or
you get a promotion or you you know you
literally win a game or whatever it is
where you have a moment where you've
worked so hard you overcame the
obstacles and you've got that moment
where you're you get the trophy you get
that feeling of wow the hard work pays
off and to have those moments and I
think Ninja Warrior is filled with that
and for so many of the people it's not
about getting to the end and winning the
money it's getting on the course for we
had a girl Daniela bright I think it was
season six I was live-tweeting the show
and she said you know if I ever get out
of bed I'd love to be on the show I'm
like why are you in bed she's like why
have stage three breast cancer and I'm
not sure how it's going to turn out and
so I sent her a t-shirt and I said well
we'll be here waiting for you the next
year well she's on the course she was up
in the first obstacle and comes out with
the biggest smile on her face
and and you know our sideline reporter
was like how are you feeling she goes I
won yeah I'm here I feel amazing and and
to see that to see someone you know what
a perspective on life when we so often
get caught up in did the Patriots win
our who care you know those are real
battles that these people are having
that we're all gonna face they're all
gonna be touched by and to remember that
you know in the face of those you can
still struggle and overcome and find
your little victories I think that's the
message of ninja where my the show's
resonated what do you make the fact that
Ninja Warrior or what Rogen is doing
with MMA like people doing physical
things seems to be actually like cool
again I think it's it's it's you know
it's a primitive part of us it's the
gladiators it's it's it's also you know
particularly as we get more and more
static as we sit around on our phones we
miss that you missed that as a kid you
miss plane yeah you missed that feeling
of one of the things that I know
rheumatoid arthritis took away from me
was my sense of physical well-being that
ability to spring out of bed and feel
like you could run around and run for
hours and and it's it's it's that idea
of to see people achieving something
physically at a high level inspires you
and makes you feel motivated I think
that that it's possible especially you
know MMA or NFL we love watching
exceptional performances with ninja what
I think the appeal is is the idea of
that could be me maybe I have a chance
to turn this around and and get back in
shape one last time and do something
amazing and I think that's you know
we're looking for inspiration we're
looking for hope I think that's part of
humanity is we want it we want to be
inspired we want to find that spark and
and wake up and feel like there's hope
in the world and that's why I love doing
what I do I love you know with Ninja
Warrior or with my comedy I want to I
want people believe feeling better I'm
you know again I love Stano
love Ari Shaffir love those guys you can
tear a crowd apart love it I can't do it
I suck at I tried doing roasts I bombed
I'm so bad I'm just like I thought
I would sell you to your face I really
suck at this big fun of me and you know
it's just it's I think that's part of
kind of finding authentically where you
are and what what resonates with you and
where you're comfortable and that's one
of the things you know we talk about
people hear this in comedy finding your
voice who you are what you're
comfortable with it and that is one of
the hardest things to do because so
often we emulate those we respect but
that's not us yeah really have to dig
inside and say where do I live what's my
sense of humor and Gary Gulman right now
if if you're a comedian or even if
you're just interested in expression
Gary Gulman is putting on a clinic since
January first he's been putting out a
writing tip every day and they've been
gold and one of the best was he put out
Ralph Waldo Emerson's essay on
self-reliance and it talked about so
often we see our thoughts reflected in
someone else and think their genius but
when it comes to us we dismissed them
because it's ours we think it's common
and it's like trust yourself trust that
you're enough it's you know I'm
paraphrasing here but I thought it was
just such a good for someone who's
creative so often you think of something
like that's not as funny as what Patrice
would have said or George Carlin would
have said but it's like no trust your
waiter on the path and just keep
developing it so before we wrap up you
mentioned so you mention that you had
cancer and you you have rheumatoid yeah
that's not saying you can't really write
it's no cure you control basically well
let's just talk a little bit about
dealing with some serious health stuff
because someone yeah that I average
person watching this looking at you like
you're jack then you're and you look
healthy and all those things but you've
you've lived through it's about and you
talk about it yeah well you know and
that was one of the things so we don't
having been a doctor or as my dad points
are you're still a doctor Jam when I was
diagnosed with rheumatoid arthritis I
found out what it's like to be a patient
and you go online and you look things up
you see the worst case scenario because
that's the textbook they show you you
know that typically deform joints and
you think this is my future and it gives
you this sinking feeling and I realized
that's why it was so important for me to
be out there visible telling my story so
that people would see there there
there's alternatives now you know
not everyone living with the disease is
destroyed by it we have incredible new
treatments and just the other day I got
a call from someone who I'd been
baseball with in college knew and he
thought he had RA and he was just he was
petrified and it was so and he's like I
was just googling it and I found he's
like I didn't know you had it I just
googled it and found you had it because
you'd talked about it and I thought you
know that's why I tell it so that this
person could call me up and I could tell
my story and say look there's hope
there's treatments don't worry about
this you know whatever it is you're
facing their incredible treatments out
there and that's why I went on Celebrity
Apprentice
that was my charity we raised a million
dollars to help with research and so
it's um look I I would much prefer not
to have rheumatoid arthritis and what
level of pain are you going through when
you realize so it started you know it
started with pain in my hand and it just
it's for those who don't know RA
essentially is an autoimmune disease
where my body attacks my joints and the
immune system erodes the joints and
causes joint destruction inflammation
and can impact the organs stiffness in
the back and neck and and so I went from
you know being working out five or six
days a week to not working out at all I
had my feet were in pain where I was
wearing clogs and limping I couldn't
sleep I was thinking like 14 hours but I
was always exhausted I gained 55 pounds
I felt like a shell of a man like I was
physically ruined and then it took 18
months to get the diagnosis and I was
going to doctors I was having blood work
it just took that long for the blood
work to convert and when I started the
treatment I got my life back and I
didn't realize how sick I was
and not just physically but emotionally
how drained I was and the thing that
kept me going was comedy was that you
know the thing that I would get out of
bed for the thing that would motivate me
was to go out and laugh and to realize
Norman Cousins was right like the
catharsis of laughter and how how good
those endorphins are how important it is
I can't overstate it and that's one of
the things I've talked about is you know
for people who are sick is talked
telling your story because so often
people with the disease feel defined by
their disease and one of the things I've
done is tried to make my stories what I
talk about rheumatoid arthritis or
cancer I want people to laugh I'm gonna
baby so to laugh about it because if
they do they know I'm okay with it and I
am okay with it like cancer I'm ten
years I'm cured in the RA I've made my
peace with it I'm I'm doing well on my
medications and I'm living the best life
I can with it so people take their cues
from you so teaching people how to tell
their story because so many people when
they tell a story of illness they feel
they can see PD in people's eyes and
that they may not want that but it's
hard to learn how to tell your story in
a way that says I'm okay with it that's
one of the things I've been working on
is try to figure out how to help people
take take charge over their disease by
doing what you can control is how you
tell your story and trying to use for me
it's humor but for you know whatever
there there's so many tools for people
who are dealing with chronic illness to
try to make it you know don't let it
define your life because it's very easy
and it's very easy to to fall into the
victim now and feeling sad for yourself
that'd be a shame if you did that
Wilford Brimley yeah you might have
diabetes feel sorry for yourself I hope
you don't alright so do what makes you
happy that's how we started this thing
and it live the best life that you can
that's how we're gonna I think you're
doing it to day so I appreciate you
having me on right on that it's been a
pleasure chatting with you thank you and
for more on Matt you can follow them on
Twitter it's Matt Iseman and that's ice
with an S thanks guys
you